so start with why wasn't supposed to be
a book and it wasn't supposed to be a
ted talk
it was born out of my own
pain my own journey
i
had what appeared to be a superficially
good life i was living the american
dream i started my own business i had a
little marketing consultancy we did good
work we had great clients um well liked
you know things were fine but i
completely fell out of love with my own
work
and people gave me stupid advice like do
what you love i'm like i'm doing the
same thing and i don't love it anymore
you know follow your bliss thank you
[Laughter]
it's perfectly true it's just not
actionable
um and so
i was very embarrassed by the fact that
i didn't want to wake up and go to work
anymore because superficially everything
was okay so i didn't talk about it and
all of my energy went into pretending
that i was happier more successful and
more in control than i felt
and that is exhausting
and uh
it wasn't until a dear friend of mine
came to me and said something's wrong
did i come clean
um and explained to her what i was going
through and it lifted a huge weight off
my shoulders
and
all of that energy that was going into
lying hiding and faking
i redirected and finding a solution to
rediscover my own passion and there was
a confluence of events and i'll spare
you the gory details but there was a
confluence of events and i made this
discovery based on the biology of human
decision making
that every single one of us knows what
we do
you know the products you sell you know
the job you do some of us know how we do
it call it your unique selling
proposition or the things that you think
are your strengths
but very few of us can clearly
articulate whether corporately or
personally very few of us can clearly
articulate why we do what we do what's
your purpose cause or belief that under
underlies everything i knew what i did i
knew how i was better than everybody
else but i couldn't tell you why i was
doing it and i realized that missing
piece was the source of my malaise i
became obsessed with understanding my
why and the most important thing was i
learned how to help other people find
theirs and i just started helping my
friends
and my friends started making profound
profound life changes and they would
invite me to talk about it with their
friends i would literally stand in
someone's living room and talk about
this thing called the y and i would help
people find their wife for 100 bucks on
the side
true
true story um and people just kept
inviting me to talk about it and i just
kept saying yes and
somebody said you should write a book
and i shrugged my shoulders and said
okay and before you knew it it sort of
became a thing and i think the reason
that both the ted talk in the book
gained such uh
sort of organic popularity because it
was driven not by marketing was driven
by people saying you should read this so
you should watch this it's completely
organic
um
uh is because i think it resonates i
think it's a deeply human thing it
wasn't designed to be to fill some
market opportunity it was it was
something that was deeply deeply
personal to me and remained so and the
key takeaways were you need to start to
understand you need to know why you do
what you do and have that be the
foundation for everything that you do
whether as an individual or as an
organization yeah
you know it's funny because uh
when we thought about this this event
today
my team actually asked me
that question what's your why what's my
why yeah it's a very difficult question
to answer not because we don't know it
it's because it and this is the biology
of it it exists in the part of the brain
that doesn't control language you know
our neocortex which is our homo sapien
brain is responsible for all of our
rational and analytical thought and
language but it's our limbic brain that
sort of old mammalian brain which is
responsible for all of our feelings it's
also responsible for all of our decision
making but it has no capacity for
language that's why we have gut
decisions i know all the advice i'm
getting tells me to do x
but it doesn't feel right i think i'm
gonna do why and you ask all the most
successful leaders or entrepreneurs you
know what's your what's your secret
they'll all say the same thing i trusted
my gut now there's no part of your
stomach that makes decisions
what they're attempting to say is i
couldn't put it into words but i could
feel
and and so we have a sense of our why
and if you have the confidence to trust
your gut it goes you know we've all done
it we've all ignored and we've all
followed it um
the opportunity to put that why into
words
makes it no longer simply a feeling that
only you can follow it now makes it puts
into words that a gives you greater
confidence in those decisions it serves
as a filter but more important is you
can share with other people so that they
understand the context of why you're
making the decision even though all the
data and advices we should do the
opposite